من دار الاوبرا في سيدني الى برج خليفه في
دبي وصوت مان في لندن وحتى تايم سكوير في
نيويورك احتفل الملايين حول العالم براس
السنه الميلاديه بالالعاب الناريه والعروض
البصريه الرائعه لاول مره منذ احتفالات
عام 2020 العالم بلا قيود صحيه الاحتفالات
بلا حذر او تباعد والناس من جميع الاجناس
تترقبوا العام الجديد وتامل في غدا افضل
اليوم نبدا
365 يوما جديدا عسى ان تكون تلك الايام
القادمه اكثر اشراقا وسلا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
واذا نذهب الى شبكه مراسل العربيه حول
العالم لكي نحتفل معهم مباشره على الهواتف
صباح العربيه نرحب بيريتا سليمان من
واشنطن مراسله صباح العربيه وايضا سلطان
السلمي من جده يسعد صباحكم واهلا بكم وكل
عام وانتم بالف خير ريتا الكلمه لكي الان
يعني نريد ان نعرف كم دقيقه حتى تدق
الساعه ويحتفل الامريكيون في العام الجديد
صباح الخير نادين صباح الخير سهام كل عام
وانتم بخير نحن في الدقائق الاولى لعام
2023 هنا في واشنطن لحسن الحظ قبل ساعه
تقريبا توقف المطر عن الهطول ولكن الضباب
بدا يلف المكان ااه حرم الكاميرا من رصد
الالعاب الناريه التي تملا سماء واشنطن في
هذه الاثناء همم دعوني اتحدث عن طقوس
الاحتفال في واشنطن هي عائليه
الجميع يتناول طعام العشاء في منزله همم
ثم همم يبداون بالتدفق على ضفاف نهر
بوتوماك الشهير في واشنطن حيث نتواجد الان
لمتابعه الالعاب الناريه في مجمل المعالم
في همم واشنطن في مختلف المناطق ان كان في
ناشونال او حتى في همم النصف بقى
التذكاريه العديده وما اكثرها هنا في
واشنطن همم الاشواق من من حولي كلها
عائليه حتى الاطفال
تخطوا موعد نومهم بكثير فقط لياتوا الى
هنا وليشاهدوا الالعاب الناريه همم في
سماء همم واشنطن لدينا الان هذه الالعاب
مستمر في هذه الاثناء امامنا وايضا من
خلفي ولكن الكاميرا لن تستطيع رصدها بسبب
الضباب الكثيف الذي بدا يلف المكان همم
هنا العائلات تحتفل وسعيده جدا حتى
الاطفال تحدوا البارد ايضا لمشاه
والاحتفال بسنه 2023 على طريقه اهالي
واشنطن همم على ضفاف نهر
طيب هل من شيء جديد مميز هذه السنه في
احتفالات راس السنه الميلاديه
غير انك موجوده
شكرا انها المره الاولى منذ ثلاثه اعوام
يتمكن فيها اهالي المدينه من الاحتفال ااا
قدوم العام الجديد من دون كرونه
والعوائق التي فرضتها كرونه وفرضتها ايضا
السلطات هنا لمنع همم
هذا كرونا ايضا من الانتشار بين المواطنين
همم الان همم كل كل هذه الاعاقه منعت
الجميع هنا سعيد يحتفلون همم
بقدوم هذه السنه الجديده بكثير من الفرح
وايضا نعم مع عائلاتهم هنا واكيد واضح
عليك الفرح والابتسامه ويديم عليك السعاده
واتمنى ان ترتدي سنه 20 23 رداء ابيض مثل
الذي ترتديه وان يكون عن خير علينا وسلامه
جميعا خلينا نشوف سلطان السلمي من جده جده
غير يا سلطان يسعد صباحك واهلا بذكرى في
اول يوم في العام الجديد كيف كانت
الاحتفالات في جده واليوم شو التوقعات
بالنسبه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه في
العام الجديد
[موسيقى]
يا صباح الخير عليكم وعلى كافه المشاهدين
صباح العربيه ويا رب يكون عام مليء
بالاحلام و الامنيات وتتحقق اهداف الجميع
يا رب اليوم مختلف في جده عشنا ليله
مختلفه ليله راس السنه وتحديدا في مناطق
مختلفه من السعوديه تحدثنا عن العاصمه
السعوديه الرياضه تشاهدت احتفالات ضخمه في
مناطق مختلفه وتحديدا او قيمه الليل طربيه
فنيه من طراز عالي بحضور قرابه 12 فنان
عربي نتحدث بمقدمتهم همم اصاله واليسا
وراغب علامه وغيرهم من الفريق الذي حفلا
جماهيريا ضخما في البوليفارد سيتي في
الرياض ان هي كان الالعاب الناريه في جده
وفي الرياض ومختلفه المناطق في الشرقيه
وغير المناطق السعوديه التي احتفلت بشكل
مختلف في جده لحظات مختلفه عشناها مساء
البارحه وتحديدا في همم بعد منتصف الليل
في كورنيش جده شهاده العائلات السعوديين
والسعوديات وكذلك حتى يمين نشاهد الزي
الاحمر توزيع الورود بين المواطنين
للمقيمين او وجود الاطفال والعائلات في
الكورنيش وفي منتجعات وكذلك في المطاعم
والكافيهات التي تزينت باللون الاحمر
واقامه الحفلات الطربيه والغنائيه في
مختلف المواقع في السعوديه كان احتفال
مختلف اليوم سنه جديده السعوديه من
المتوقع ان نشهد يعني التغيرات مختلفه
احداث مختلفه نتحدث على مختلف المستويات
الرياضيه وثقافيه واقتصاديا وتنمويه ليوم
السعوديه مقبله على مرحله مختلفه من
المشاريع النوعيه تحدثنا مشاريع القديه
ومشاريع البحر الاحمر ومشاريع اليوم
وغيرها من المشاريع التي سوف ترى النور في
مراحل معينه خلال مجرى هذا العامه في
مناطق مختلفه من السعوديه الحفله الحفل
كان مختلف مساء البارحه في الرياض حضور
جماهيري كبير في بعض المواقع المجمعات
الترفيهيه في السعوديه تحدثنا عن مدينه
الرياض ومدينه جده اجواء مختلفه عاشوا
السعوديين استقبل العام بابتسامه كبيره
بامنيات باحلام يعني طالب من الله ان يتم
تقبلها منهم وان تكون سنه مختلفه وسعيده
على الكل نعم
بحر شكرا جزيلا لك السلطان السلايم ونشكر
جزيلا زميلتنا العزيزه الغاليه يا ريتا
سليمان شكرا جزيلا لكم استقبلت مدينه دبي
العام الجديد باحتفالات شده انظار الجميع
اليها تم استعمال الشهب الاصطناعيه التي
اضاءت برج خليفه بشكل خاص واضفت عليه
رونقا جميله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
العراق في اجمل حلتي خلال احتفالات العامه
الالاف في جميع انحاء العاصمه بغداد شارع
المتنبي ومنطقه المنصور فرق موسيقيه
والعاب ناريه
لا يزال يوزع هدايا على الاطفال ومن
العراق الى تركيا حيث اسطنبول
العام الجديد
الاحتفالات من اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من اسطنبول ينضم الينا مراسل صباح العربيه
سنه سعيده عليك كيف احتفلت اسطنبول في راس
السنه الميلاديه
قناه العربيه وصباح العربيه كل عام وانتم
بالف خير وسنه خير ان شاء الله وسعاده
وفرح
بعيدا عن كل المناقيسات وبعيدا عن الاوبئه
والصراعات صباح الخير صباح سنه جميله وان
شاء الله مليئه بالحب والسعاده طبعا اول
شيء سهام ونادين سلامات كثير من عشرات
الاشخاص اللي التقيناهم عشرات العرب
الموجودين في اسطنبول يوم امس اثناء اجراء
مقابلات همم سلامات كثير للصباح العربيه
من الجاليه العربيه هنا في اسطنبول طبعا
همم احتفاليه احتفاليه خاصه كانت يوم امس
في اسطنبول للمره الاولى او للمره الثانيه
همم الاحتفالات بدون الوفاء لكن هذه المره
بدون اي اجراءات وقائيه والتباعد اجتماعي
غير موجود لذلك الاحتفالات كانت صاخبه هنا
في اسطنبول تحديدا في ميدان همم تقسيم
وشرع الاستقلال في نيشان وايضا في كاليكو
في الجانب الاسيوي هنا العشرات بل ال الاف
وصلوا الى مضيق البوسفور حيث نتواجد الان
مع الاسف الضباب غطه قليلا من المشهد في
الخلفيه التي همم وراءنا او في المشهد
الذي خلفنا مضيق البوسفور مغطى في صباح
اليوم الاول من هذا العام بالضباب لكن همم
هذا الدواء لم يمنع الالافنا الوصول الى
همم مضيق البوسفور والاستمتاع بمشهد
الالعاب الناريه واحتفل هنا في بدايه
العام الجديد الاجواء في تركيا عاده في
هذه المناسبه هي اجواء عائليه بامتياز
الكل يتجهز يتجهز الى هذه المناسبه همم
قبل عده ايام التحضيرات الالاف زين الشرف
همم الشرف الشرفات المنازل همم هنا ايضا
الشوارع اكتست بالاضاءه الجميله
شجر شجره الميلاد في كل مكان همم الاجواء
كانت مميزه هذا العام
طبعا اعود الى موضوع الاتراك وكيف يحتفلون
في هذه المناسبه كما ذكرت الاجواء عائليه
بامتياز الجامعي يجتمع هنا في البيت مع
طبق الديك الرومي المفضل لدى الاتراك في
ليله راس السنه ايضا العائله تجتمع
الرسائل يتم تبادلها بين الجميع لكن طبعا
الجيل الجديد بعض الجيل الجديد يفضل
الاحتفال في بعض المطاعم يوم امس هنا في
مضيق البوسفور كانت السفن او الاحتفالات
داخل السفن السفن همم انطلقت فيها تمام
حوالي الساعه 9:00 مساء مع الالاف الذين
همم خرجوا في او ذهبوا في السكون في جوله
سياحيه واحتفلوا بدايه راس السنه هنا في
مضيق البوسفور بالعموم نتحدث انها كانت
ليله جميله جدا همم الامنيات بان تكون
العام المقبل عام جميل هناك عشرات
الفعاليات التي تستضيفها مدينه اسطنبول
وايضا تركيا في عموم همم في خلال هذا
العام نتحدث
لعشاق الرياضه نهائي دوري ابطال اوروبا
سيكون هنا في اسطنبول شكرا
زيدان
التي رحبت بالعمل الجديد بعرض ضوئي فوق
ميناء فيكتوريا حيث سميحه بتجمعات في
المدينه بعد ثلاثه ايام فقط من رفع القيود
المفروضه بسبب تفشيكورا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
افريقيا تفتحش القاره السمراء تدخل العام
الجديد من مصر في الشمال الى جنوب افريقيا
ومن نيروبي الى ابو جعفر من القاهره
على الاجواء وكيف كانت ليله امس
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الى القاهره مراسله صباح العربيه ندى
حجازي ندى يسعد صباحك اهلا بك يا ندى كيف
احتفل يا هلا بهالطله يا ندى كيف احتفلت
القاهره براس السنه الجديده
احنا عندنا يوم راس السنه ده مهم جدا جدا
بالنسبه للمصريين اجتماعيه ونفسيه وحتى
على صعيد الشغل وكل حاجه ده يوم مميز جدا
والناس بتعتبروا بدايه جديده لكل حاجه في
حياتهم وده حتى بيبقى ظاهر جدا على
السوشيال ميديا ودائما الناس اللي هي
بتكتب بقى الاهداف بتاعتها والحاجات اللي
هم ناويين يسيبوها تمشي مع السنه القديمه
ومهما كانت السنه صعبه اللي انتهت دائما
المصريين بيبقى عندهم انا لو طموحات
وبيعملوا اللست كده لاهدافهم علشان يبداوا
بخطب جديده طبعا احنا عندنا الاحتفالات
بتبقى في كل مكان اي شارع هتدخليها تسمعي
موسيقى
وزمامير سيارات فانا كيف بدي اتخيل انه
ليله نيو يير كيف بدها تكون الجو شو راح
يختلف اكثر راح يكون مضاعف في العشقه ولا
كيف
والله هو بقى يعني يوم راس السنه برده
زحمه بس زحمه مبهجه عارفه كده يعني زحمه
تحسي الناس متقبله زحمه اكثر من اي ثاني
دائما الناس بتكون في الصبح كده في الزحمه
بتبقى حاسه ان هي متعطله
بس في يوم راس السنه احنا بنحب نروح حتى
الاماكن الزحمه وبنحب يعني يشارك فرحتنا
نعلن هو اللي ما نعرفهمش
وفي كثير بس في ناس كثير بتقعد في البيت
برده زي بقيه البلاد وزماني بنتكلمه في
ناس كثير بتحب تقعد في البيت بس دول مش
الاغلبيه لكن في ناس بتعزم عائلتها كمان
في البيت وبيعملوا عزومه كبيره واللب
والسوداني
العائليه الجميله
اللي احنا بنحب نجيب جديد بدالها يعني
هتلاقي الناس دائما بتتخلص من الهدومها
القديمه انا مش حابينها اي حاجه عندهم
حابين يجيبوا بها جديد بيتخلصوا منها شكل
الشنطه جديد
وبرده البنات دائما يروحوا يصبغوا شعرهم
ويبتدوا يعملوا نيولوكس جديده برده عشان
احنا دائما بنات كده بنحس انه انا لما
باغير لون شعري
ابقى شخصيه جديده هبقى عندي يعني حياه
جديده
شكرا جزيلا لك من القاهره وننتقل الان الى
تونس الخضراء احلام العبدلي مراسلتنا من
هناك اهلا بك يا احلام كيف احتفلت تونس
صباح الانوار لكم
العربيه سنه سعيده جميله ملئها الحب
والفرح والصحه والسعاده انا طبقت نصيحه
حتى زميلتي ندى حجازي عملت اليوم
بمناسبه العام الجديد ههه
ليس المصري فقد قل ايضا التونسيه احيانا
هي قمنا في نيويورك في العمل الجديد في
الحقيقه سنه 2003
تقبل بكثير من الامنيات التونسيين لنقل ان
العنوان الابرز لسنه 2022
وتضررت منها كثيرا تحررنا منها همم في هذه
السنه كان هذا العنوان الابرز ونقبل على
سنه جديده التونسيون من اكثر الشعوب التي
تحب الاحتفالات تحب الاحتفالات خاصه
بالمرتبات وبالحلويات همم تاثرا همم
المطبخ الفرنسي والع الفرنسيه نحن نعرف
علاقه الشعب التونسي بالمطبخ الفرنسي
واقباله على هذه الحلويات والمراتبات
التونسيون يحتفلون سواء خارج المنازل او
داخلها هناك من يتوجه الى المطاعم الى
السهرات الى
الحفلات الفنيه والنزول وهناك من يحتفل في
البيت ويخير ايضا الاحتفال العائلي
التونسيون ينظرون دائما
وامل كبير الى سنوات الجديده يعقدون
الامنيات اخر كل سنه ويتبادلون التهاني في
اجواء حميميه واجواء رائعه و رائعه جدا
فالحقيقه هي هذه السنوات مجرد ارقام لكن
في التقليد التونسي دائما يستبشرون خيرا
بسنه جديده او بتاريخ جديد ويتمنون لبعضهم
ان تكون السنه افضل من سباقاتها كما نتمنى
ان يكون ذلك على كل العالم وعلى كل
الانسانيه يا جماعه يعني احلام اول شغله
بدي اقول لك
مش الف ركنيهما بيقول ههه نعيما على همم
اصلا النظر لالك فرحه يعني انت هيك شكلك
وابتسامتك
وخصوصا كمان هلا على نيو يير في يعني ندى
بتقول لك انه حطت لست لاهداف للسنه
الجديده انت في اهداف براسك كمان هيك لسه
مثل ندى
ايه طبعا هناك احداث ننتظرها واحداث ربما
نتمناها ان تحدث وانا في الحقيقه اريد فقط
ان اقول ملاحظه ان هذه السنه
مجاملات اللطيفه والتحذير الجميله
والجميله جدا من زميلتان نادين سهام في
ستوديو صباح العربيه
دائما هذه الملاحظات التي اعيش الملاحظات
اللطيفه في الحقيقه حتى المتابعين صباح
العربيه في تونس وحبدونها ويحبدونها جدا
شكرا على كل هذه الموجات الايجابيه وكل
هذه اللمسه من الحب
ميناء السعاده التي تمنحوني اياها في كل
مره اكون فيها في اللايف معكم اوه طبعا يا
احلام نحن نقول التونسيين نحبكم برشا وكل
عام وانتم بخير شكرا جزيلا لك
واحنا بنحبك برشا